l'ethiopie ne fait plus aujourd'hui la
une de l'actualité
même si le pays est toujours en proie à
d'énormes difficultés
la tragique famine qui a touché ce pays
est aujourd'hui enrayée et pour ce faire
l'aide internationale n'a pas manqué à
l'appel
la mobilisation humanitaire et venues du
monde entier
la région champagne ardenne a elle aussi
participé à sa mesure à ces aides il y a
deux ans le conseil régional avait donné
sept cent mille francs bernard stasi
s'était d'ailleurs rendu sur place
à cette époque il y a quelques jours une
délégation régionale est retourné sur
place pour mesurer l'oeuvre accomplie
une de nos équipes étaient du voyage
cette balance pour peser les enfants et
tout un symbole
elle représente l'ombre du patient
1985 c'est l'époque de l'aide d'urgence
de la mobilisation générale pour sauver
tout un peuple
touchés par la famine parmi toutes les
organisations non gouvernementales
l'une d'entre elles actions
internationales choisi de s'installer
dans les provinces du nord en erythrée
le conseil régional de champagne ardenne
participent à cet élan en finançant une
partie de l'opération
non
deux ans plus tard le problème de la
malnutrition a été résorbé les centres
de secours se sont transformés en
centres de soins une structure
hospitalière complète à remplacer les
toiles de tente actions internationales
grâce à l'argent reçu peut désormais
développer tout un programme de
formation médicale
c'est le but principal de leur action et
de l' usage des crédits accordés bon
actuellement il ya plus de problèmes
nutritionnels en pathologie tropicale
courant c'est-à-dire paludisme et
diarrhée infantile essentiel maintenant
l'aspect curatif est un peu gérer l
excuse pour être présent et il ya
beaucoup de travail à faire mais notre
but et du petit à petit de passer toutes
ces parties curative au ministère de la
santé tient
puis nous de prendre en charge la
formation d'agents sont et communautaire
la formation de ses assistantes à des
techniques plus particulière de façon à
pouvoir améliorer la qualité de la santé
globale des gens dans la région ici
pourquoi vous faites payer
parce que en fait c'est important que
les que les gens fassent un effort pour
venir qu'il faut pas développer un
assistanat complet on s'aperçoit que la
somme qu'on leur demande aucune somme
très faible et que ça n'empêche
absolument pas les jeunes venus les gens
viennent y compris pour des pathologies
de saint bénigne et préfèrent payer un
petit peu et venir nous voir tesson
binic et au détriment
l'eau une richesse naturelle en mairie
craie dans cette région montagneuse
cette ressource abondent encore
fallait-il l'exploiter actions
internationales avec les associations
paysannes a réalisé tu es un programme
d'irrigation et depuis
au total sur la commune de rama 22
hectares ont été julien et les 40000
habitants disposent de 60 mille litres
dont pur par jour
toutes ces réalisations ont fait l'objet
d'accords avec les ministères de
l'agriculture et de la santé
un travail en commun qui n'empêche pas
une certaine vigilance
l'équipe d'action internationale doit
souvent discuté pour interdire tout
détournement
et au niveau de l'eau il a fallu aussi
qu'en se bat pour quelqu'un insiste sur
un prix réel qui passeront au prix de
revient de l'installation et non pas
après ce qui aurait permis de financer
autre chose pas comme par exemple
financer quelques manifestations ou
quelques constructions en pareil cas
précis préserver son indépendance donner
toute l'aide internationale au peuple
éthiopien
c'est la tâche d'actions internationales
une mission difficile à remplir dans un
pays en guerre